Is copywriting still worth it in 2026?
Well, copywriting is only two things.
It's sales and writing. So, let me ask
you, do people still sell in 2026? And
do they still write in 2026? If the
answer to both of those questions is
yes, which it is. Like, this is such a
dumb question. Yeah, it is Of course it
is. Everybody sells and everybody
writes. Writing is still the number one
medium of communication across the
world. Writing is in text messages, it's
in websites, it's in emails, it's even
in videos like this. This is a written
script. You write for all of these
things, social media content. So,
writing is embedded in everything that
you do. And sales, which is really just
an underlying word for persuasion, where
you're persuading someone to click
something, to join your email list, to
buy whatever. All of that has
encapsulated and been around since the
days of Jesus, and it ain't going
anywhere. So, understanding copywriting
isn't something that you could just
prompt Claude to do for you. It's a
mindset and fundamentals that you have
to embed in your brain if you want to
grow your business, grow your list, do
whatever it is to be free in your work.
If you like the sound of that, you
should probably learn copywriting.